you're sitting in your office and you
know that for the next day you still
need to create an extensive slide
presentation of 10 20 30 pages so what
do you do you just work all night to do
that do you want to think about the
layout of every single slide in
extensive way no this is surely not what
i would recommend you to do what you
need are some very good design and
layout principles that you can rely on
to just produce just produce the deck
without needing to think too much about
how every individual's life needs to
look like this is exactly what i want to
talk about to you today my name is
heinrich i'm a former mckinsey
consultant and on my channel i want to
help you to create slide presentations
in the same style the leading consulting
firms like boston consulting group or
bain do and today we're going to talk
about slide layouts and throughout the
video you're going to see lots of
example slides and i will offer all of
those to you as a download as an open
powerpoint file so you can use them for
yourself as a template there's a donor
link to them in the video description
feel free to check them out and before
we jump in i want to say thank you to
thinkself for sponsoring this video
things that is a tool that i literally
use almost every day to improve my
powerpoint slides you will hear more
about them later today the key principle
i want to talk about today is that every
slide is a table when creating slides
you should always think about organizing
the information on the page in a table
format so what i do not mean by that is
that you should indeed just insert a
table in powerpoint as it maybe looks
like here on the slide but instead you
should always consider your page being a
collection of rows
and columns and always organize your
information in this framework so every
slide is a table but what exactly does
this mean so in order to make this a
little bit more tangible i will
structure this video along three main
types of slides first qualitative slides
second quantitative slides and third
integrated slides we want to integrate
both qualitative and quantitative
information so let's directly jump into
the section on qualitative slides and
i'm gonna always start by first showing
you a general slide blueprint and then
some actual examples so you can bring
this format to life here's your basic
layout for a qualitative slide like that
i hope you directly recognize the table
format in the columns you have the
different types of information that you
want to talk about and this is one key
thought that whenever you have different
types of information you will include
them in different columns this is an
error that many people are doing they're
just having a page just with a list of
bullet points and then maybe the first
bullet point is about a general
principle the second bullet point is
about an example the third bullet point
is about a suggestion that you're making
you're mixing different types of logical
information different logical types of
data you should always then separate
this in different columns then in the
rows you will typically present
different types of information that you
apply the things that you talk about in
the headers too the general idea is to
avoid just a long list of bullets to
avoid these so-called clothed lines with
no idea what a clothesline is and why
you should avoid it i created a video
about that in the past i will link it
somewhere above here for you to
reference it's very key concept check it
out if you haven't seen it yet so for
the theory let's look at a couple of
practical examples so here you have a
version of this very slide so we have
first the column for the measures so the
different measures that you're proposing
and then on the right or column for the
rationale so why do you think this
measure is needed and you have nicely
organized all these measures in rows of
course this is a very wordy a very text
heavy slide so likely not something for
your main deck but maybe something for
appendix but i think it nicely
illustrates the principle or with this
table format you can very nicely
aggregate and show this data next there
may be a little bit more complicated
version of such a page you have a first
column with the name of the
recommendation that you have a second
column with the details what exactly is
it that you're recommending a third
column with the abbott impact that maybe
you're estimating to include it as a
number and then an additional column for
the roadmap for the timing of it all
again notice how different types of
information are stretched out to
different columns and then the logical
elements that you want to talk about are
organized in the row this is a very
typical standard slide format that you
will be able to create in a quite quick
and straightforward way and again all
these slides that i will show you here
in this video offered to you as a
download in the open powerpoint format
check out the link in the video
description if this is of interest to
you next just an additional layout idea
to illustrate that you don't always need
to follow the strict column format with
the column headers of course for the
columns you can also use other elements
for instance here in this example a
timeline or maybe also process chart
with different process bars that you
could use for the columns so you can of
course play with it include some
creativity in it so the slides surely do
not need to look all the same and you
can mix it up as needed next let's look
at quantitative charge so charts that
have some data visualization on it some
charts some diagrams on it of course
this is a very common charter probably
the majority of all the charts that you
will create at least on professional
services so let's look what you can do
with the layouts in here so before we do
that let me introduce you to a tool that
i learned to love during my career in
consulting it is a tool that is used by
almost all the big consulting firms it
is the de facto standard to create
professional slides in the style of
leading consulting firms like mckenzie
bcg and bain and this tool is called
think sale it is a powerpoint plugin
that up until this day in my current
role in a startup company i use almost
every single day it is a tool that
nicely integrates in powerpoint and even
if you feel like that you do not need it
at the moment just the fact alone that
it is used by almost all of the big
consulting firms should be reason enough
for you to pick up the basics of it
because this is a tool that you will
likely be expected to use on a very
regular basis in many of the big
consulting firms so if consulting is a
career that interests you better pick up
the basics on things that this will for
sure be very well invested time things
that doesn't only help to create
effective and beautifully looking charts
but also has lots of functionalities to
help to create a good and sound layout
on your pages following the style that i
will teach to you here in this video and
the best thing is that i actually
negotiated a special offer with
thinkself for the firm learning
community if you sign up to thinkself
via the link in the video description
you get first of all a 60-day free trial
this is double the usual size no credit
cards required or any other hidden costs
and then if you do decide to continue
using things that after the trial you
will be offered single licenses this is
usually not possible in the things that
offering but with this link here for the
foreign learning community you can
purchase a license just for yourself so
this does sound interesting to you try
out things that we have a link in the
video description i can personally very
much recommend the tool let's now jump
into quantitative slides what you see
here on this page is arguably the mother
of all quantitative slide layouts and
again i hope that you directly recognize
the table formats on the first column we
have a column on the methodology that
you applied here for your data analysis
and the second column we have the chart
with the data visualization that you
want to highlight and then in the third
column we have a column on the
implications of this page what is the so
what of this page frankly easily 50 of
all the pages i created in consulting
followed some version of this very basic
layout and in many cases you don't even
need the first column on the methodology
you have more space than for the chart
for the data visualization can fit that
out and then focus on the right with a
couple of bullets what the implications
indeed are what the reader recipient of
your presentation is actually supposed
to take away from this chart but let's
look at a couple of examples this would
be a very basic layout following exactly
this methodology so on the left you have
the diagram showcasing here in the
bubble chart format the market size the
growth the profitability the margin of
certain regions and then on the right
you have a simple column highlighting a
couple of points a couple of key
insights that you want to communicate to
the reader here again this layout is
very basic but i hope you agree if you
produce a slide like that you will never
get the feedback that this is not
looking professional this is a very
solid page always just following this
very basic layout that we just discussed
next example here a simple waterfall
chart because the truth is that
sometimes you don't even need the
additional column on the right maybe the
chart out of itself is already
self-explanatory or maybe you just want
to highlight a couple of points within
the chart then you can do it with this
little element that you see right here
this is something that is sometimes
called a call out right so just the text
box with two line elements to showcase
that also just the variation of this
layout that we just discussed let's now
move to the third type of slide and
these are integrated slides and these
are arguably the most interesting ones
because the truth is that this is a
style of creating slides that i think is
very very common in professional
services in consulting if you work for a
firm like mckinsey bcg bain but it's not
that often seen outside of consulting
and this is a style where you're trying
to integrate the diagram the chart even
more into your table with the text so
earlier we've seen this very simple
example maybe on the left you have a
charter diagram and then on the right a
list of bullets with implications and
again this is surely okay you can do
that but now the problem maybe the
downside is that now there's a certain
disconnect between your bullets and the
chart people now need to read the
bullets and maybe they find something
interesting and now they need to look at
the chart and now they need to try to
make the link and especially if the
chart is maybe a little bit more complex
this is often not so easy it for sure
takes additional cognitive energy of the
person looking at this to make sense out
of all the information that are
presented here and so the idea of these
integrated charts and let me maybe
directly jump to an example is to really
integrate the chart together with
additional bullets with other
information into the table structure
again here you see a chart where on the
left you have a title and then you have
a simple bar chart then a column with
details and an additional column with a
strategic assessment and also notice how
this additional call out there on the
right this in the end of the day nothing
else then an additional column that was
inserted there so always think about
whether it makes sense whether there's
an opportunity to include such a diagram
into your table structure and don't just
have two very separated columns where
then on the left you have a diagram on
the right you have a list of bullets of
course this doesn't always make sense
but often there is a good opportunity to
do something like this and then this
really helps the reader to just process
the information in a more direct way
let's look here at an additional example
here on the left in the first column you
have this waterfall chart then second
column this additional number dimension
with the circles and then on the right
you have this column with implications
so again this is not too far away from
this qualitative blueprint we talked
about earlier but notice how here
there's this shade on a very specific
part of the diagram where again you
really try to integrate the information
provided to the right with this very
specific element of the chart again this
is just an additional little tool that
you can use to integrate the information
more to create these nicely integrated
slides that we're talking about here but
in the end of the day this is nothing
else than a table format again so hope
this makes sense and now you understood
what exactly i mean by treating every
single slide like a table as i told you
earlier if you are interested in
downloading any of these slides there is
a download link to them in the video
description to an open powerpoint file i
once again want to extend a big thank
you to thinkself for sponsoring this
video there's a link to things that in
the video description as well and via
this link you will have access to a
60-day extended free trial and also the
opportunity to purchase single licenses
which is usually not possible with
things say if this video provided any
value to you at all please destroy the
like button for the youtube algorithm
and also subscribe to the channel and
turn on notifications to stay up to date
on my content big big thanks to the
members of him learning your support is
very much appreciated as you know i'm
heinrich the creator of this channel i
release weekly videos so very much
looking forward to next saturday so if
you want to continue developing your
slide writing skills i will insert here
an additional video on slide writing
next to me so check that out looking
forward to see you again soon all the
best to you